I love it and we love it too Kylie
Jenner just showed off a new do and not
only are we totally here for it but so
are her famous sisters thank you on
Tuesday the 22 year old makeup mogul hit
up Instagram posting this sexy shot
that's Kylie rocking a racy blush
colored corset and milk chocolate brown
locks looking fire AF I'm excited about
it the new hue is just the latest look
for Kylie who has gone both blonde and
pink in recent weeks it's fun and her
hairstylist Chris Appleton revealed that
those brunette locks are real she
actually opted to dye her hair instead
of wearing one of her signature wigs
Chris shared this clip of Kylie on
Instagram writing colored Kylie's hair
light chocolate brown who's into it I'll
tell you who's into it Kylie's older
sisters
that's who Kim Kardashian slid into the
comments writing damn I am loving at
this hair color Khloe Kardashian chimed
in quote this is your hair color
I literally just fainted gags dead all
of that and Kylie's mama Kris Jenner
wrote gorgeous with a few heart emojis
Kylie appeared to be rocking the new due
for a photo shoot and she shared tons of
videos and pics of herself with her glam
team on her instace stories Kylie also
shared this boomerang where she's
sporting blue contacts which she noted
made her look a whole lot like her pal
Stassi but Kylie isn't the only
kardashian-jenner to play with her look
during quarantine you know you see Dave
my hair Ren Kim recently debuted her new
summer do a nice shade of fire-engine
red to her Instagram stories - love it
oh we love it big time I was sitting
there and I was like why not the beauty
mogul flaunted a low pony
I just wanted to really
then it went up into a messy bun Chloe
also mixed it up going all out brunette
for her 36th birthday I love it
yep that's Coco lookin straight fire
sands her signature blonde locks she
captioned the shot quote birthday glam
bTW I'm loving my brown hair she added
that the new hue was giving her a little
something right now yeah us too Chloe
us too and we aren't the only ones
Chloe's ex and the father of her
daughter true Tristan Thompson commented
on the post with fire heart and heart
eye emojis
[Music]